poi risponde fa vi potreste iniziare un
tuo video mostrandoci di cosa te ne fai
di tutta quella nutella ragazzi vi
presento l'angolo nerd qua si vanno a
finire diciamo tutte le nutella che
diciamo non sanno proprio poche se avete
notato comunque quasi metto diciamo di
tutto quindi ragazzi in risposta a
questa domanda e mi state facendo i 2
miliardi ultimamente in tutto ha
risposto a posso garantirvi che molto
presto mi crollerà la mensola
tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog come al solito ragazzi prima
di cominciare iniziamo con la panart
della settimana che o mio dio questa
settimana è stata vinta da un maschio
impossibile la fan alta è stata fatta da
mario ed è e di stupendo cioè non c'è
niente da dire per la prima la prima no
però non lo so non è successo tante
altre volte che ha vinto un maschio
sappiamo anche noi di segnare fa e
infatti ragazzi anch'io ho deciso di
cimentarmi nel disegno e per una volta
sono stato io a farvi una fan art a boy
e spero che mi piace ragazzi perché ci
ho messo tantissimo la fan art della
settimana ed i favi j
beh ragazzi si troveranno tantissimo
tempo vorrei passare le news
ultimamente molti di voi hanno notato
che non sto facendo serie tipo stabili
come tipo outlast oppure come rame di fa
del resto perché sono serie le serie che
continuano mi richiedono più tempo
perché ovviamente dovrei di stare tutti
gli episodi e questo ragazzo e diciamo
un periodo nel quale veramente un casino
riuscire a registrare vision sto dando
il massimo quindi sto facendo
videogiochi abbastanza corti che di un
episodio due al massimo e più avanti
ovviamente inizierò di nuovo tutte le
serie che mi state chiedendo tantissimo
alcune che mi piacciono un casino alcune
tipa monde sleeping verbis virtus che
usciranno quindi state tranquilli che
dirò pace nervo soltanto trovare il
tempo per farli quindi lasciate passare
diciamo questo periodo un po così e poi
iniziamo a bomba per quanto riguarda le
serie di adesso ragazzi avete notato che
ieri ha stoppato aggiornabile il gai
perché veramente ragazzi io non ce la
faccio più no io vi giuro quello non è
un regime quella uno strumento di
tortura cazzo nonostante questo la news
che volevo darvi che stiamo raggiungendo
i 300.000 iscritti con una velocità
incredibile
ragazzi io vi giuro non ho parole per
questo perché non ho idea di come cazzo
sia possibile alla prossima settimana
dovrei registrare lo speciale che sarà
veramente un casino da fare e speriamo
venga bene ragazzi perché ci sto ci
tengo veramente tantissimo e quindi
ragazzi da domani cercherò di lavorare
allo speciale quindi è possibile che
domani non esca il video e durante la
settimana capiterà anche forse una o due
volte non lo so perché mi prende
veramente tanto registrarlo ma verrà una
cosa epica del questo l'importante
ragazzi quindi aspettatevi di tutto
quindi ragazzi direi che con le news
abbiamo finito e direi di passare a
farvi risponde
ai pacchi ragazzi mi dispiace ho finito
i pacchi erano tantissimi e definiti
tutti a fuori a richiedermi né altri e
non ne ho più scusatemi
allora ragazzi siccome i pacchi non ne
ho neanche uno insomma stavolta ho
deciso di farne due break
perché sono veramente se non l'avete
notato sto scherzando sono un po tanti
cazzo di ragazzi cercherò di aprirne tre
che sono questo e qualcuno mi deve
spiegare che cazzo ci hanno messo qua
dentro quale transformers ancora mi
manca quei ragazzi questi altri due un
po più piccoli ma sempre enormi come
pacchi perché è assurdo e questo non ho
capito che il cazzo è perché c'è una
forma stranissima probabile comunque
vedremo dopo e come continua ragazzi
volevano aprire st busta facciamo finta
che sia un bonus una cosa del genere
anzi ragazzi di inizia da questa perché
il cazzo sono troppo curioso di vedere
cos'è
[Musica]
cosa dovrebbe rappresentarmi sta roba io
vi giuro non ho veramente parole cioè a
parte il fatto che legge il 5 di gta
messo su fa vj e la cosa più [ __ ] che
abbia mai visto io non è da vera mente
di chi abbia fatto questo ma vi giuro a
tutta quanta la mia [ __ ] stima perché
epico cioè non ho mai visto una fan art
così al di là della faccia non guardo
mandate la faccia ragazzi che potrebbe
sviarli guardate tutto il resto è
fantastico da gianfranco federico amico
mio per i volti non c'hai tanto gusto ma
per il fisico e direi di passare al
prossimo pacco quello più piccolo tra
tutti mi avete inviato il videogioco il
videogioco di death note originalissimo
fantastico e io sono keira ok
dopodiché altre due fan art con tassi
che fatte dal simone e ignazio
fantastica che queste quel queste sono
io in versione manga come cazzo solo
sexy in versione manga
ragazzi secondo pacco quello intermedio
diciamo come grandezza questo ragazzi
pesa un casino non ai dari che cazzo sia
perché la forma è particolarmente strana
ok una pergamena look me guardami
ragazzi imparano del drago gusto
epico ragazzi epico farà sempre un
ministro che non sa telefonate
fantastiche ultimamente vi giuro e come
ultimo ragazzi siamo giunti al pacco più
piccolo di tutti in modo una parte il
fatto che pesa 4 tonnellate e mezzo
quindi a meno che non si tratti di un
cucciolo di elefante cosa molto
probabile non ho proprio idea di che
cazzo ci può essere qua dei propri giuro
ma è enorme io non mi sembra di sgozzare
una tigre del bengala essere umano
trionfa sempre sugli animali
[Musica]
le budella ragazzi mi sto facendo troppo
prendere lo sa chi cazzo dovrebbe essere
questo una specie di doraemon super
sayan alla quarta un piccoli brividi
formato gigante ma che cazzo un
braccialetto di plastica con scritto
offrì ragazzi io sì così li amavo un
casino la piccola che facciamo sempre
così
reja c'era un sacco di detto rosso palco
c'erano 250 quintali di roba è l'ultima
cosa che non ho capito che cos'è
effettivamente questa credo di sapere
che cos'è però non non lo so ma sono
sicuro perché esageratamente imbacuccata
quindi vediamo ci sono che avevo detto
io questa è la e la cat mariella questo
ogni volta facciamo un qualcosa di
diverso di volti volta c'era la favella
la fabi della e quindi ragazzi direi di
passare al paris rispondeva vi risponde
mai l'orecchino se paghi risponde perché
hai deciso di farti fare delle domande
in cui tu devi rispondere ragazzi in
verità l'idea è partita dal fatto che mi
faceva arte esageratamente troppe
domande
la cosa poi le deteriorata nel senso che
alla fine sono andato a rispondere a
domande per fare le scenette ma in
teoria l'idea di principio è nata perché
dato che avevo troppe domande le facevo
nei blog così almeno rispondere un po a
tutti i blaster ma vi rispondo e quanto
ai matematica 7 fa visse il mio mondo ok
partì un disegno in faccia
[Musica]
ragazzi vi presento il d'artagnan con la
cicatrice di harry potter fantastica tra
l'altro questa dovrebbe in teoria doveva
essere una lacrima mia uscita benissimo
e non sono più sexy così va bè ragazzi
siccome mi avete cominciato così non mi
sono conciato da solo mi avete pitturato
voi eravate voi che comandava te la mia
mano ammettetelo perché non avrei mai
fatto una cosa del genere comunque
ragazzi e direi di chiudere qui episodio
perché oggi proprio non avevo tempo di
infatti non dovevo neanche farlo questo
video ma l'ho fatto lo stesso perché non
mi va di lasciarvi il sabato senza blog
perché ovviamente sabato 20 a blog non è
un sabato e quindi ragazzi se è vivo è
piaciuto e siete segretamente innamorati
di cat mario da quando avete scoperto
che ha un fisico da paura
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come nani vino frate
nella descrizione serre degli iscritti
iscrivetevi non ci rivediamo un prossimo
vinto dai ragazzi